dabei ist luca meine damen und herren
das ist jule hat herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem video der gugl play
game on kampagne das ist eine kampagne
bei der jule und ich in diesem monat und
auch noch im nächsten monat soll noch im
januar sehr interessante geile games
spielen werden und in diesen games
challenges machen werden körbe wir
fangen hier heute direkt an mit dem
ersten spiel und zwar asphalt 9s was das
ist auto spielt ihr aber das auto
porsche 718 kämen aber du kannst lesen
gewünscht das ist das auto was ich mir
tatsächlich gekauft haben das ist mein
neues auto diesem spiel
jeder von uns wird heute zwei rennen
fahren in diesem spiel und es gibt zwei
verschiedene steuerungs arten und zwar
einerseits den touch drive modus aus das
heißt man muss wirklich so das gerät hin
und her neigen um mit dem auto zu lenken
und im zweiten rennen werden wir diesen
touch drive modus dann wieder
einschalten das heißt da haben wir dass
die karre von alleine verden von alleine
lenkt und wir nur nitro geben müssen
driften müssen und uns für wege
entscheiden müssen
das hier ist das erste rennen das fahre
ich jetzt hier und ihr seht schon oder
ich weiß nicht ob man sieht aber ich
muss auf jeden fall so gerade lenken das
oben ist mein gott ich bin ich bin
erster das geil ist ich kann jetzt hier
links gedrückt halten und dann kann ich
treffen und dann seht ihr schon ich hab'
ich will ich mein erster also natürlich
dann mit dem porsche bei dem rennen ist
das auch nicht so schwer an nicht erster
zu werden
juli fährt jetzt hier ihr erstes rennen
also ist die gleiche strecke die ich
gerade gefahren bin
wie schlägt sich bisher tatsächlich auch
gar nicht mal so schlecht dachte daran
dass sie das du hast zwei doch was alle
vernichte bisher fast well sech also
juli sammelt hier auch nitro einen genau
dann kannst du bekommst du musst da
draufdrücken honig gedrückthalten ok
juli zerstört nur leute da ist das ziel
und julia ist meine gefühle 360 grad
drehung
also bei dem ersten rennen wurde ich
erster du wurdest drittel aber du hast
halt unfassbar viele andere leute
vernichtet jetzt werden wir hier unten
auf touch drive anklicken und ich fahre
jetzt mein zweites rennen mit touch 3g
und es geht los freuen ich mache mal
direkt nitro juli wenn du doppelt auf
niedriger oder wenn du hier doch mit
plumpen trick sei dann machst du solche
drehungen und jetzt siehst du schon
junge habe ich oben mein nitro komplett
voll das heißt ich kann jetzt doppelt
hier drauf gekommen ist ein turbo schuh
und jetzt fährt der welche quasi durch
oben kann man dann immer aussehen ob man
links oder rechts erfahren möchte zum
beispiel jetzt gehe ich mal recht
seltsame ich nicht vor allem jetzt halte
ich hier links dürften gedrückt und nein
er war bisher so schnell um die kurve
driften und durchstreift kann ich jetzt
dürften einfach gedrückt halten das
heißt der glückliche vor noch lang
die jetzt genau nehme hier die stände
mit und ich benito
ich habe kein einkommen schnell macht
patronen hier schön um alles rum driften
hier noch nitro mitnehmen jetzt so man
diesel turbo boost aktivieren kommen
macht so 360 ins ziel
[Musik]
du kannst gar nicht mehr gewinnen
der dritte
[Musik]
juli versucht hier trotzdem noch mal ihr
glück in ihrem zweiten rennen
man muss allerdings auch wenig dazu
sagen dass die karte die ich mir gekauft
habe den porsche der porsche 718 cayman
der ist vom rang her sagt ich mal sehr
weit über den rahmen den man sage ich
mal mindestens benötigt bei diesem
rennen bzw
bei dieser bei dieser gruppe hier damit
man die chance hat in diesem rennen
jetzt wenn er beispielsweise gleich so
zwei optionen gruppen stehen kannst du
dann halt nach links und nach rechts
beim 12 jetzt kannst du genau das jetzt
fährt er über diese rampe drüber und
dadurch sammelt dort wieder noch ein
bisschen nitro also juni zerstörte recht
die ganze zeit andere leute die mit
ihrem fan bist auch gerade wirklich auch
erst das hat das geile bei diesem tag
schreibmodus dass man halt wirklich sich
auf nitro einsetzen konzentrieren kann
oder auch driften et cetera pp bist du
nur noch erste alte dass es echt hat
relativ gut hier findet natürlich auch
ein link zu diesem spiel in der infobox
verlinkt und findet auch bei link in der
infobox tatsächlich wo google play die
besten spiele 2018 aufgelistet hat also
wenn ihr allgemein euch denkt hey jetzt
ist gerade winter zeit was ich zu hause
und ich hatte bock auf ein paar neue
spiele dann ist in der infobox unten
unter dem video ein link wo ihr du bist
ja schon fast im ziel da findet ihr auf
jeden fall die besten spiele 2018 in
google places juni wird auch erste krass
das war wirklich glückwunsch ja also
jule ich habe das erste rennen mit dem
ersten platz abgeschlossen die mit dem
dritten platz was aber auch nicht so
schlecht ist aber trotzdem schlechter
als ich das zweite rennen habe ich auch
als erster abgeschlossen und juli
tatsächlich auch als erste meiner zeit
war allerdings besser als deine von
daher habe ich beides eigentlich
gewonnen
du kannst in der aufnahme nachgucken ob
ich vielleicht hallo hier ist der
schiedsrichter luca aus dem schnitt ich
habe mir tatsächlich die zeit noch mal
angeschaut und das hier ist meine zeit
und das ist jurist zeit also sie war
tatsächlich schneller als ich das heißt
dieser asphalt neuen challenge geht
unentschieden aus
das war es mit der heutigen challenge
wenn euch das video hier gefallen hat
das gerne mal ein leichter in den
nächsten wochen kommen auf meinem kanal
noch drei oder vier weitere videos zu
anderen spielen wie beispielsweise
pokémon go oder sims werden wir auch
eine challenge gegeneinander machen das
ist mega cool wir befinden uns jetzt
allerdings auch in der endart freunde
wenn euch das spiel was wir gespielt
haben gefallen hat und
denkt hey asphalt neue hätte ich auch
mal zu zocken dann könnt ihr einfach auf
das logo was hier verlinkt es
draufklicken könnt euch das spiel
herunterladen und hier findet ihr auch
noch ein weiteres video von mir
verlinkten könnt ihr euch auch gerne
ansehen
du hast das letzte wort